okay let's talk about the economy today
Donald Trump has been touting the
current economy as the best ever Trump
has been bragging about how strong the
economy is in general he says it's the
best it's ever been for black Americans
the best that's ever been for Hispanic
Americans and he usually points to
unemployment rates and the stock market
being high and yet at the same time 40
percent of the population is still
struggling just to pay their basic bills
every single month which is more than a
hundred million people in this country
how is it possible that we have the best
economy ever and 40 percent of the
population is struggling to pay their
bills and to really understand this you
actually have to zoom out because it's
bigger than Trump of course when Trump
says something like this is the best
economy ever it's meaningless political
hyperbole but there's a deeper analysis
to be done here that is beyond
left/right politics or at least it's
beyond Donald Trump so let's do it
it's true that the economic expansion
that the US has seen dating back to the
beginning of Barack Obama's presidency
is on paper the longest economic
expansion in the history of the United
States of America that's true as defined
as we define expansions and still we
know that a huge portion of the country
can't even afford an unexpected $400
emergency expense how is it possible
that both are true the stock market is
at record highs the unemployment rate is
historically at its lows and yet there
are a record number of people who are 90
days or more behind on car payments
which is a concerning indicator that can
predict economic trouble and that number
continues to climb every single month
that's not good how can there be on
signals on paper that things are so good
and at the same time nearly half the
country can't pay its bills and the
answer effectively boils down to one
word if we need to boil it down to one
word and that word is inequality it's a
little simplistic but in a sense it's
all about that one word inequality I'll
explain the economic expansion dating
back to Obama has been hugely unequal
the gains in the stock market that we've
seen dating
to Obama are hugely concentrated in a
very small portion of the population
that owns the vast majority of the stock
so for a huge number of people even
though on paper the stock market is way
way way up it does very little for a
huge number of people that don't own any
or almost any shares of stock wage
growth wage growth has gone mostly to
the upper tier net worth growth has gone
mostly to the upper tier stagnant wages
on the lower tier so again on paper you
can come up with broad averages that
look good or at least look okay but for
a huge portion of the country cost of
living has continued to go up but their
inflation adjusted wages have not so
they can't pay their bills even though
on paper they should be okay
unemployment is low and the stock market
is high just as very little for a lot of
the people living in the United States
of America so when you go all the way
back to nineteen eighty nine thirty
years ago the bottom half of the country
is less wealthy today inflation adjusted
than they were thirty years ago this is
stunning given the economic growth that
in total the United States has seen in
the last thirty years
and the explanation is inequality or
specifically unequal growth in almost
every aspect of the United States
economy and the problem with this is
that the economy is in a sense hanging
by a thread
even though so many numbers look good as
Donald Trump talks about there are like
a hundred million people in this country
for whom even a mild economic setback in
the broader economy can push them into a
completely unsustainable financial
situation this could include a
bankruptcy this could include having to
rack up crushing credit card debt at
high interest this could include a home
foreclosure or an eviction from a place
that they rent vehicle repossession and
of course remember that in the back of
our minds is the possibility that a
medical bill could bankrupt us
completely our health insurance system
fundamentally weakens the economy
because of the system that we have
people who are even in an okay financial
position are still at risk of losing
everything because of unexpected medical
bills
may not be covered by their insurance
that's how the system works that's how
the country works which sheds a lot of
light on the reality that our health
insurance system is an economic
liability beyond just being a moral and
ethical liability so the thing about all
of this is that because these things are
so political each president each party
they always want to take credit for any
wins they can take credit for they want
to shirk responsibility for any of the
losses that they can successfully shirk
responsibility for that we end up unable
to have the real serious conversation as
a result this is actually bigger than
Republicans and Democrats now it's true
it's not totally apolitical it's true
that historically Democrats are better
than Republicans in terms of stock
market returns but that doesn't affect
everybody equally it's true that
historically Democrats are better than
Republicans in terms of the average
unemployment rate during their
presidency
but that doesn't actually tell us
whether people are making a living wage
or whether they have to work multiple
jobs in order to make ends meet by the
standards we use Democrats are better
than Republicans but unfortunately those
standards fall very very short and these
are just bigger issues that don't even
enter into the political election cycles
that we have of two four and six years
two years for the House of
Representatives four years for the
president and six years for the US
Senate respectively automation and
technological unemployment is one of
those issues inequality is another one
of those issues education costs are
another issue that around the margins
you will hear politicians talk about but
nothing serious has been done to deal
with that
the health care system fortunately it's
entering more into the political
discussion particularly since the since
2010 and Obamacare and Bernie Sanders
mainstreaming the idea of Medicare for
all in 2016 but this is why you hear the
economy is the best ever
and there are actually some numbers that
sort of seem to reflect that in some way
but yet almost half the country is
hanging by a thread that's not going to
change listen if the stock market if the
Dow goes to 30,000 still a huge portion
of the country will be at risk of a $400
unexpected expense throwing their
financial situation into total disrepair
you are not going to change that if the
unemployment rate goes from three point
eight to three point seven percent
okay these are bigger systemic issues
and inequality if I had to sum it up in
one word tells us a lot about why this
is the case let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other 7 million users by clicking
the link underneath this video
[Music]